and you may be seeing more people
putting on those masks back
on this weekend as large crowds are
expected on the strip for fireworks
sunday night and several concerts
and events throughout the weekend
madison kimbrough is live from allegiant
stadium where a big electronic music
concert
is taking place this weekend in madison
we have to ask are visitors taking the
new concerns seriously
christian there has been some mixed
reaction you know from the strip to the
las vegas sign visitors we spoke to
really say that they want to explore but
they're doing it with caution and even
here at allegiant stadium
the weekend is sure to be crowded
las vegas has always been a popular
destination for the fourth of july
and this year there will be energy like
never seen before
very very busy but it's ok because it's
worth the wait everywhere you go the
options for something to do and see
are endless along the strip from miley
cyrus headlining a new day club at
resorts world
to bruno mars at park mgm an allegiant
stadium hosting
electronic edm dj millennium and we
can't forget
fireworks we've just seen sights taken
in some restaurants
trying to take it a show but it's so
busy that we couldn't get a ticket to a
show
while visitation is up so are coveted
cases and unfortunately the highest in
the nation
so are visitors aware and do they feel
safe it's really scary
my husband and i have been vaccinated
but my kids have not yet
they wear masks in california but here
it was different i'm feeling pretty okay
with the numbers and
the safeness a lot of the staff and
waiters everywhere have been wearing
masks which makes me feel more
comfortable
being in dubai it's a requirement there
so you walk around so we're used to it
it's not a
it actually felt kind of strange to walk
out and not have a face mask on
there are no specific vaccination
requirements to attend events in las
vegas but a reminder for this weekend be
aware of your surroundings and really do
your part
to keep safe again there's going to be a
huge event happening here at allegion
stadium
tomorrow edm concert so look forward to
that reporting live madison kimbrough 8
news now